how's gum Rasmus beer back welcome back
to second son last episode we jumped off
that bridge went pretty well I would say
we have these cool new abilities put all
this up in one week it's amazing
ready to get all the funding from my tax
in my knee it's [ __ ] with a couple
of my cop buddies
try and get access to the police
database copy buddy the meantime need
you to just lay low might spook I show
up with a bioterrorist okay we're gonna
walk through here and I want to mess up
it's like when you have to walk through
the immigrant thing in from the
airport's when you're entering USA so
you always feel like a criminal even
though you haven't done anything they
will ask you these weird questions alone
because I'm Swedish and I I usually
travel from you cane like why do you do
that are you a terrorist
are you a terror oh damn like have you
ever seen a dancing terrorist no well
then I'm obviously are innocent do you
see these moves do you see these moves
son yeah yeah guys please look I don't
think they can see it that's a shame my
brother made two it's my turn now do you
see this I didn't work any mouths do you
see sorry Oh actually
oh did it work
it's shaking I'm gonna have to murder
you must be some weird bug behind the
system isn't it
Oh God my brother already attacked sorry
let me to melt your face or anything can
I save him I'll save him
I'm samosas it's my cop
my brother cops shooting them where you
just funny oh yeah I got awesome super
abilities come on show me your titties
got it thanks
Oh God there are a lot of them all right
all right I'm doing it there we go
where are they tower and they are guys
don't do that
who dat who dat don't do that you dead
in Gy sorry
first the smoke I need smoke I need a
sniff no come on give me some smoke jet
pack
there you go you're welcome by the power
of a samosas out of energy find it where
it must be one somewhere maybe the vents
has him there we go
yeah so smooth
don't do coke rose it's not good for you
that's what I'm told
freakin amazing hi how are you by the
power of samosas what didn't you see I
just performed a miracle on that man's
goddamn races y'all racist
Oh more more people need my touch up
hand abduction there you go I knew all
this hand ups would one day give me
super powers are they shooting civilians
[ __ ] stop it
[ __ ] oh come on that thing is covering
there you go thank you
are they all dead now that does feel
good I'm like spider-man but smoke it's
like smoke man oh my god okay full
command center got it so what exactly
does one look like
all right I think I see it
badass RV with lights and metal crap on
somewhere the way it's la macchina
come on what is happening
I mean I'm I'm out of here like that um
don't kill me I just need a smoke
am I gonna have to kill all of them
there's so many what was he doing just
staring he's like what am i doing we're
laughs is that a camera thing nope
hey we do that all the time that's
adorable and see ya have some smoke up
here
yeah that we do awesome yes good
I like the gameplay but I wish I had
more attacks or whatever it's kind of
lame to just keep shooting with them
with my give you you know I'm saying
shoot it is know can't even do that the
shotgun attack [ __ ] made stones
explode how can they not kill these guys
alright smoke says alright I think we
killed them all
oh this is the thing cool amazing
amazing okay yeah it's like that thing
right is that a Starbuck copy what does
it say let me cafe con go east a dork
wasted oh Lord oh okay high five that
power core you're my best friend Power
Core
oh no we're not compatible that I
thought we were we had something
comparable oh I think I just made him
come and he destroyed everything
I'm a copy you must be back BAE EDIUS
exam goal in armor wait hold on a second
is that a poem Factory oh how do I deal
with this guy Oh God
retreat charge and my fire but there we
go oh god oh god oh god that was close
oh I know you're in there oh what a cute
little butt come here
that's adorable got him Haley I'll save
you by smacking your face Betty yeah you
can go home find the DP DUP why those
shards here I want to upgrade my life
why did you go what did I kill him here
all right let's touch him oh god what'd
I do that that is a nasty all I said the
water bowl oh my god I shipped him so
much yeah great advice what's going on
here Queen okay missions let's open this
for them there you go you're welcome
maybe you're they're like horrible
murderers or some [ __ ] why did they make
that face we should be [ __ ] happy
you're free just go
need you to send the locations to my
phone what Wow my own brother wants me
to fight the ultra mega bioterrorist of
all time with less powers well guess I
shouldn't put it off then better go
straight on to Augustin now and get it
over with
not sure what's gonna happen
search core relates to gain new smoke
powers and we did that already
oh [ __ ] we're not gonna stream this
shame let's see what this world has to
offer it's a whole new world I jump on
cars and make super - hello my litter
oh you're not friends smack your yeah I
murder your friend you better
they're [ __ ] everywhere like what am
I supposed to do
are you milking my tits right now cuz I
don't [ __ ] get it maybe get some
bubble tea I love bubble tea it's the
best
oh my god please open no some I just
like supposed to clear out these
military bases or whatever or am I
supposed they don't even know where I am
they're so lost seriously that's
adorable
hi friends I almost my murderer guy but
I mean to do it alright here we go Oh
what just happened I'm flying how did
that all right oh oh yeah yeah give me
all the powers gasp that perv phase two
what do we get
cool now we can power a beanie press r1
to fire cinder all right they're welcome
okay cool we have a new power let's get
let's get more powers before we try and
fight people I'm gonna be as LP as
possible oh I thought that you knew it
is I'm in it for boobies alright let's
fly there should I on the wings of smoke
flash smoky pie smokers loves to
motorboat BAM that's amazing let's check
this place out see if there's something
good let's try and land on that guy's
face
those [ __ ] how dare they
oh don't be sad oh no what happened to
your smokers will heal all all who
follow samosas shall join my sniper clan
most 360 noscopes smoke scopes as I like
to call them there we go and you power
what do we get per face I can now drop
needs which will stun their faces
l1 to throw a non-lethal alright take it
take it please
there we go thank you join us take a
smoke and join us he just gives up it
doesn't need a smoke to give up that's
adorable it says there's a shard here
let's go and get it really quick where's
my shard [ __ ] drugs are dangerous and
illegal holy [ __ ] how many people are
there here what are they doing
I just straight-up murder all of them
almost not you though and you join us
where's the drugs drugs are bad and okay
drug bust drug murder is what it should
be called okay the last place I love
that face never gets old
what do we got brofist power yeah yeah
by the power of hand
press oh how convenient bro
fished yeah
samosa spares all who will join him that
is amazing let's do that again
[Music]
why not being so nice to them I want to
get at least three what what come on let
me kill come on
mom it's games [ __ ] that's all so
what do they do to that tower Ellison
has spent his life climbing the trees
and sheer rock walls in Soliman Bay so
Seattle is a [ __ ] there's a new day
it's a new laughs it's a new Seattle I'm
walking what is what is he doing girl
shut up Space Needle [ __ ] your car
that's what you get that's what you get
all right let's find this Space Needle
that he talks about it's one of those
signing people you're not doing a very
good job dance didn't work I don't
understand why they call us terrorists
like we're so nice people to everyone
all right whatever guys spray yes yes
all right how do we do this
a gnome run so I can choose the motive
depending if I'm good or evil I love the
spray tan all right this is good thing I
had this in my back pocket always ready
oh this one is a bit more detailed he's
moving the line as a powerful message
behind that one old people moving grass
that's how dare they
oh there we go he's moving the gnomes
poor little gnomes why would you do that
oh my god okay here's the mission
starvation yes the needles tricked out
with all kinds of electrical crap and
what looks like a bad aluminum siding
job I want to do that so bad
to be awesome it's crazy to be awesome
all right we're gonna have to do that in
the next episode Bruce hope you enjoyed
this episode thank you for liking and
commenting on this video and thanks for
hanging out with me today bros as always
stay awesome bros bro